the framework agreement follows weeks of
closed-door negotiations in the senate
it's one of the first bipartisan gun
control agreements in decades
we haven't had significant federal
legislation in nearly 30 years so having
a framework announced having 10
republican senators along with 10
democrats signing off on that which
would avoid the filibuster in the united
states senate it's a really big deal
the tentative agreement has been
welcomed by president biden who's
tweeted
i want to thank senator chris murphy and
the bipartisan group for the gun safety
proposal it does not do everything that
i think is needed but it reflects
important steps in the right direction
with bipartisan support there are no
excuses for delay let's get this done
but some don't want it done i think it's
deeply disappointing that republican
leadership decided to get in league with
the democratic conference in the senate
to put together a gun control bill
you know
that should be a huge red flag for
republican voters going into the fall
significant proposals include incentives
for states to pass so-called red flag
laws which allow a judge to decide
whether a gun buyer or owner poses a
potential threat to others
federal background checks on buyers
under 21 would include access to their
records as minors
and federal funding for mental health
care and increased school security
but these measures fall well short of
what's being demanded by gun control
advocates including president biden
himself
at rallies across the u.s saturday calls
were made for a ban on the sale of
semi-automatic weapons and high-capacity
magazines and for the age at which an
individual can buy a rifle to be raised
from 18 to 21 to match the existing
federal law concerning handguns
assault rifles were used in the mass
shootings in uvalvi texas and in buffalo
new york in each case they were wielded
by 18 year olds
the senators have set an informal goal
of passing the bill before the 24th of
this month when congress goes on a
two-week recess
but with the legislation still not fully
written it's unlikely that this goal
will be met
[Applause]
and it's certain that the modest
suggestions will do little to ease the
mounting pressure on politicians to pass
meaningful gun control measures
or face the consequences in november's
midterm elections
mike hanna al-jazeera washington